your success every day success is a
daily thing not a destination thing if
you can believe it you can achieve it
and that never quite rang true with me
this something-for-nothing
entitlement mindset that invades so many
people's lives is a bunch of garbage
too many years are like they're like
travel agents they're sending people
where they've never been themselves and
you want to be a tour guide you want to
take people with you he's an American
author speaker and pastor who's written
many books his books have sold millions
of copies worldwide with some making the
New York Times bestseller lists Inc
magazine named him the number one
leadership and management expert in the
world he's John Maxwell and here is my
take on his top ten rules for success
rule number eight is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end for some special
bonus clips the first thing I want you
to know that success is is not a
destination it's a journey think of
success as a process let me let me
illustrate it and explain it this way if
you go to college you work hard and then
four or five years depending on what
kind of degree you're working on it and
in today's society sometimes six or
seven years but but eventually it comes
the day of graduation and you're all
excited and your family is there and
your friends are there and and you're
there with your classmates you've got
your cap and your gown and and you know
that there's going to be a time in that
ceremony where you're going to walk
across stage and the president Provost
somebody's going to shake your hand hand
you the Paloma congratulate you and and
you're going to get off the other side
I'm gonna have presents waiting for you
and they'll be taking pictures and
everybody's shaking your hand say
congratulations today you become a
success your college graduate doubt now
my friend you did not become a success
the day that you got your diploma now
what you did have happened to you in
that ceremony is you got recognized for
success the Diploma is recognition of
what you have done the previous four or
five years you see you are a success in
your freshman year when you decide
not drop out of school like some of the
other classmates and decided to stick to
it and you were success every time you
studied for a test and you were success
every time you did a project or or did a
writing assignment you see you're a
success all through all through school
you're a success
every day success is a daily thing not a
destination thing the day you got the
diploma
you just got recognized for the success
that you already were
now that's very essential because so
many times people have it have a
tendency to devalue the moment today
what they do is they greatly value the
destination and so they kind of talk
about well when I get there or if I
arrive there or when I do that or when I
accomplish this and they don't
understand that success is a daily thing
and I'm here to share with you that the
secret of success is determined by your
daily agenda in fact I wrote a book a
few years ago called today matters I'm
passionate about that book because what
it does is it helps you it helps me to
understand that we make decisions and
then we manage decisions and and too
often we think I will make a decision
for example you're saying I'm going to
make a decision to be a coach or I'm
going to make a decision not you know
what I'm going to make a decision to be
a public speaker I want to be a
communicator well congratulate gun
congratulations you've made a wonderful
decision coach speaking good decisions
but that won't make you a successful
coach that will make you a successful
communicator it's not the decision that
makes you you've got to make the
decision by managing it and you manage
the decision on a daily basis in other
words what you want to be tomorrow
you've got to do today you visualize
tomorrow that gives you hope
but that's your motivation and that's
your dream you nothing wrong with that
you visualize tomorrow
but you value today what's that mean
that means that what I do every day is
either getting me closer to that vision
that dream that goal or it's really
driving me farther away from it you see
every day we are either repairing or
we're preparing you see if I messed up
yesterday guess what I get to do today
fix yesterday in other words if I didn't
do the right thing yesterday what I got
to do today is I've got to repair I've
got to go back make amends backtrack put
the car in reverse put my life in
reverse I've got to go back there I've
got to repair now every day I spend
repairing I'm not spending preparing
well you see we repair when we fail to
manage the decisions that we've made we
prepare when we on a daily basis manage
the decisions that we've made so your
footprints to success are really
footprints of success because every step
that is made and taken based upon the
goals that you have for your life and
you're managing those goals correctly
every step is the progressive
realisation of success in your life and
by the way oh well you'll get the
Diploma you'll get the certificate but
but when you get that you didn't arrive
it just is another step in preparing you
to reach your potential
each one of us should live our life as
if we'll never learn everything we never
need to learn we'll never be able to
accomplish everything we wanted to
accomplish we won't be able to
experience everything we wanted to
experience we should live our life every
day hungry understanding that we are to
live until we die you see I think
success can't be summarized in a
flippant degree or program or diploma or
arrival I think today if you are
learning
to coach if you aren't learning to speak
if you're doing the things that are
essential to the decisions and you're
managing those decisions well can I say
something to you congratulations you are
already a success now guess what
over time it shows up you've heard the
expression you maybe even to set it
yourself
you've heard the expression I'm sure I
worked all my life to become an
overnight success so it works all of a
sudden somebody recognizes you all of a
sudden somebody congratulate you you
didn't get good at that moment you've
been good for a long time it just showed
up some day have you ever heard a
motivational speaker tell you that
attitude is everything I'll bet you have
I've heard many say that in fact they'll
say something like if you can believe it
you can achieve it and that never quite
rang true with me so I began to press
the issue and I have come the conclusion
that attitude isn't everything
now I'm not disclaiming or in any way
being disparaging about attitude because
I think attitude is very important but
if anybody comes up to you tells you
that attitude is everything I don't buy
into that that's not true
for example attitude can't replace in
competence if you're incompetent you can
be very happy but you can still be very
unsuccessful
now here's what I do know attitude isn't
everything but attitude is the main
thing that'll make a difference in your
life
because I believe that I wrote the book
the difference-maker
you see that's what attitude is attitude
is the difference maker you have two
people side by side that you're thinking
about employing in your company both of
them have the same background same job
description education experience I mean
you could almost flip a coin in second
hire the wet one on the right or I could
hire the one on the left but one has a
great attitude and one has a bad
attitude now who you gonna hire you're
going to hire the person with a great
attitude why
because it was the difference-maker in
areas of choice you need to work on your
weaknesses for example and say I let's
say I am I'm lazy that's an area choice
that's I mean I'm not naturally lazy I'm
just lazy it's a choice so I need to
work on that because I think in areas of
choices you can make
vast improvement and you can make fast
and prove I've never heard this
distinction but yeah yeah yeah actually
helpful oh yeah in choices so attitude
does let's have a lousy attitude one day
I wake up I said this isn't getting me
anywhere
I gotta have a good attitude you can go
from a zero to a ten I mean oh won't you
see people that you say my gosh
overnight they just ya got good and
happy
you don't say okay that's a choice vast
fast growth in choices in giftedness DNA
wiring your growth is very very small
and it's very slow so I think for
example a person can maybe increase
their giftedness skill set maybe two
numbers Wow so if I'm a if I'm a little
bit above average I was six if I really
work hard I can get become an eight but
but an eight is powerful yeah eight has
a huge return so what I tell people is
in in areas of giftedness that's where
you have to work on your strengths if
I'm a two in something I'm very weak in
a skill if I worked hard I could only
become a four it still be bit elaborate
yeah that's what I tell people is you
got to ask yourself is going to give me
the return so in the area of strengths
you've got to pour yourself into the
things that you're already good at
because that'll really set you apart
from average yeah but in areas of
choices go for those weaknesses because
you and I don't you know people that are
highly skilled but they have a lousy
attitude or they're not soft
they're not self discipline attitude and
they're never gonna they're never going
to they're never gonna get anywhere and
they're going to get anywhere because
they didn't so in areas of choices work
on your weaknesses but in areas of
strengths and skills just work on your
strengths well Paul Harvey said that you
can tell you on the road success because
it's uphill all the way
and I'm here to tell you this
something-for-nothing
entitlement mindset that invades so many
people's lives is a bunch of garbage I
can promise you nothing that I've ever
had worthwhile did I have just kind of
fall into my lap like oh my goodness I
won the lottery and I and I once while
people win the lottery basically the
people that win the lottery half of lose
their money within three years the money
they won and it's because they got money
but they never changed the way they
thought and kind of taste something if
you have all the assets in the world but
you don't change the way you think
you'll lose all the assets in the world
and and what I have discovered that in
this whole process of trade-offs is that
every step of the way of my journey I
have to trade something off and it's for
you that are young the good news is your
trade-offs will never be easier than
when you're young because I remember
when I when I smart when Martin I
started out I think man you know I give
up everything I want it I was I was a
pastor to go in the ministry I gave up
everything and then I start smiling I
thought I'm sure I gave up everything I
didn't have anything to give up what I
did I was a kid you know what I mean I
had a 1964 Ford Falcon and you know
u-haul trailer and five pieces of
furniture and life was grand and off we
went
here's what I've discovered kid and I
think that I want the audience don't
want everybody watching around the world
to know today and this is very simple
the more successful you become the
higher the trade-offs are you see we
make a mistake thinking it gets easier
it doesn't get easier gets harder and
the more you have every time you go back
and say am I willing to risk that again
the more you realize wow I'm not sure
I'm willing to risk this and what I've
learned is the moment I stop making
trade-offs is the moment that I plateau
and life is continually filled with
trade-offs in your life and in my life
we I express all the time can you've
heard me but you say this you have to
give up to go up when somebody comes and
says John I want to be a leader I was
asking the question why why do you want
to be a leader I mean do you want to be
a leader because you want a corner
office you want to be a leader because
you like to be in control you like to
want to be a leader because you love to
be in the front of the pack you want to
be a leader because you want to have a
good parking place what do you want to
be a leader because leadership is an
easy leadership a lot of times isn't fun
leadership a lot of times it's kind of
lonely there's only one reason to be a
leader and that is to add value to
people and you and I will only add value
to people if we truly value them I have
a nonprofit organization equipped this
trained almost 2 million leaders
internationally around the world and I
kid you not as I go to developing
countries twice a year and I travel
internationally and I sit down sometimes
I have the privilege of being in the
offices of presidents of countries and
as I watch these developing countries
the thing that is the cardinal sin among
leadership so much is that they have
leaders of their countries that truly
don't value the people and if you and I
don't value people we will devalue
people number two if you want to add
value to people you have to make
yourself more valuable you just have to
get better you have to keep growing you
have to keep learning you have to keep
developing why very simply if you're
leading the pack you've got to be able
to give what you have and you can't give
what you don't have and so therefore
you've got to put a lot of good stuff in
so you can pass it on to others and
share with them and and add value to
them thirdly if you want to add value to
people you have to know and relate to
what other people value you and I have
to walk slowly to the crowd we have to
listen we have to care you see great
leaders are first of all listeners and
then their learners and then their
leaders they really do take their cue
from the people they understand that the
key of leadership is connecting with the
people that you lead and the only way
that you and I ever connect is by caring
enough to listen
number four is very important to me when
I'm speaking in the business community I
always share with them that for them
there are three ways to add value to
people but for me there are four and I
tell them I'll give them the three and
then there and so I'll I'll spend maybe
an hour doing those three things I just
shared with you talking about how to add
value to people and inevitably when I'm
done with the three somebody raise their
hands
John you said there for you there was
four but you said there's only three for
us I said yes it's nothing personal but
this is about my faith and so I don't
really need to share this with you it's
because I'm trying to help you and I I
don't want to cross boundaries with you
and never ever they'll say but John tell
us what yours is and I'll say well okay
you can hear mine but don't write it
down in fact don't listen because number
four for me is if I really want to add
value to people I have to do the things
the God found you see the greatest
motivational principle in the world the
greatest motivational principle in the
world is that people do what people see
and too many too many travel agents too
many travel agents they're like um or
too many leaders too many leaders are
like they're like travel agents they're
sending people where they've never been
themselves and you want to be a tour
guide you want to take people with you
you want to say this is the area where
I've been this is where I live this is
the area where I lead come along and
follow me and at level number three your
leadership begins to gain credibility
because now you are fleshing out for the
people around you and you are modeling
for them things that they want to see
and you are starting to produce how
would you tell us to develop a habit of
curiosity well you know what people do
look at me and see me as creative
because I've written so many books and I
am curious but when I started off in
college in in my in my freshman psych
class they gave us a test that he
preached dude to take on creativity and
there were seventeen in that class I can
remember it well and I was at the bottom
of the class on creativity I mean I was
like number 17 out of 17 and and and
what the teacher posted the scores and
so I mean I saw how bad I was
and and then I really felt bad not only
because I wasn't creative but I was
going to go pastor I was going to go in
the minister I was going to teach I was
going to do sermons and then I got to
thinkin to myself I'm going to be
another boring preacher and you know I
thought just grip I thought oh this is
going to be awful I'm gonna bore people
all my life you know what I mean and I'm
going to
ask them to pay while they hear me I
mean this is an awful deal so it and so
two things I did and I talked about it
but when as I started filing I started
taking thoughts and quotes and the
reason I started doing that is I thought
if I'm not going to be good at what I
say I need to quote somebody that is
good and so I started filing things that
other people would say so I'd go around
and I'd say well Kim said you know what
I mean and Jo said and Suzy said and so
that at least I would be a little bit
more interesting and that's how it
started but the big breakthrough the big
breakthrough ahead was and this will
help everyone if how many of you would
like to be more creative let me let me
see your hands okay how many of you'd
like to just absolutely have an
imagination that just took you to a new
level you know I'm sorry okay how many I
already have that because you're on
drugs
okay okay okay well here's here's that
here's the key this will work for you I
promise it work for you because it
worked for me I made a major change in
my early 30s from just having answers
and being a leader that just had to cast
vision show everybody what I was doing
and where we were going and I started
asking intentional questions and I
became a person I ask questions all the
time every day I ask questions and I
have found just asking questions we'll
take you on exciting journeys more than
thing else you're brett you excel in
that kid I've watched you over the years
you did excel really on that but for my
early years I didn't ask enough
questions and so therefore I didn't get
enough ideas and thoughts from others so
when people say I want to be more
creative what step one step number one
is ask more questions just go to people
and start asking questions it's amazing
what you learn in Switzerland there are
some mountains that can be climbed by
people like you and me we got to get a
little bit better condition but I mean
it's not like the mountain climber
mountains that would be way beyond our
skill level but but but some of these
mountains that can be climbed by you and
me that it takes a day to get to the top
and then that you just camp up there and
you come in at down the next day and on
many of these places where in
Switzerland where you could do that
about halfway up the mountain is what
they call the halfway house halfway
house half way up them out so the group
of people starts off with a guy in the
morning and about noon you kind of tired
you've been walking now for four or five
hours and here comes that you're coming
to the halfway house it is just a it's a
wonderful sight because as soon as you
enter in the halfway house you can smell
the food and they're getting ready for a
good lunch and you sit down there's a
fire in the fireplace and there's nice
soft chairs and you can just rest your
body and refresh your body and and so
the people go into the halfway house and
they eat and laugh and enjoy and and
just really really just kind of take in
that that wonderful refreshing
atmosphere about an hour and a half
after be in the halfway house the guide
gets up and says well gang it's time to
put on your gear we we got a hike we got
to get on up the top this is a fact
about half the people decide not to go
on up to the top they're sitting around
the table and they're just saying you
know what go on up and you're going to
be come by here tomorrow you'll be
having lunch here again tomorrow
we're just going to hang here and and so
the people that want to get to the top
they put their stuff on and they kind of
leave and the rest of the people sit
behind they you know eat a little bit
more food get around the piano sing some
songs get around the fireplace enjoy the
fire warm themselves by the fire
no I've played games all afternoon kind
of enjoy themselves but about 4:30
chordal 5:00 in the afternoon without
anybody saying a word the people who
stayed in the halfway house they slowly
go over to where the window is the big
window and they start looking outside
and they start looking up at the top of
that mountain and as they look at the
top of that mountain they see their
friends their friends are now getting
the tents out and they're getting ready
to prepare for the night and it becomes
very quiet very somber because everybody
in the halfway house realizes the
mistake they've made they've they've
they've they've sold their mission for a
little bit of comfort for a few hours
next morning down come their friends and
by noon they come into the halfway house
when they come in a half they are
laughing they're high-fiving they're
talking about what they've seen where
they've been experiences the fact that
it was almost
possible get up there in fact they had
to help each other get up there and how
they join teams and held hands and and
they just telling all these stories and
talk about the pictures they've taken
and they yeah they got the group picture
up there with the flag at the top and
the people who remain behind they don't
say much they just eat their lunch and
then follow the rest of them down to the
bottom of the hill where their friends
are waiting for them and those who paid
the price and went to the top who
understood now is the time to reach the
mission they hug can tell stories and
celebrate and the others they just kind
of slip off and get in a car and go home
because they realize they're never going
to be what they wanted to be they're
never going to see what they wanted to
see they're never going to do what they
wanted to do because they fail to
realize whether the halfway house now's
the time to rest and they go on
connecting increases your influence in
every situation for the foundation of
the teaching today I want to make sure
that we really have a grasp of why
connecting with people is so vital so if
you'll go to the very first sentence in
your note the number one criteria for
advancement and promotion for
professionals is an ability to
communicate effectively that I do
believe I think the ability to connect
and communicate so number one criteria
for success with your family with your
marriage with your children with your
friends in the workplace the marketplace
in the community if you have the ability
to connect with people if you can
communicate and connect not just
communicate it takes you and literally
gives you an I a decided edge over
others in the advancement of what we're
trying to accomplish for example in your
notes presidential historian Robert Alec
says that the success that successful
presidents exhibit five skills and
qualities that enable them to achieve
things that others don't so he's talking
about leaders and
presidents and people what makes some
achieve better than others here are the
five things they do well number one is
vision number two pragmatism number
three consensus building the ability to
put together to you and get consensus
number four charisma and number five
trustworthiness being a trustworthy kind
of a person now what is interesting
about these five these five things that
set the better presidents apart from
maybe the average ones for the five deal
with connecting visitors are definitely
a connecting skill the ability to to
cast a future vision consensus building
getting people to work together you have
to be able to connect to do that
charisma of course that's why people
follow the quote the Pied Piper and
trustworthy four of the five of the
skills needed to be successful as a
leader had a lot to do with connecting
so let me define connecting because
that's what this book is all about
connecting is the ability to identify
with people and relate to them in such a
way that it increases our influence with
them in other words we can identify with
them until they say he or she
understands exactly what I know and what
I'm going through and we can relate with
them until we because of that ability we
begin to increase our influence with
them and of course what do I teach about
leadership very simple leadership is
influence I think success first of all
is knowing my purpose in life as I have
watched and observed successful people
what I have discovered about them is
they really have figured out why they're
here they really do have their act
together and knowing their purpose in
life is a stability for them so that
when everyone else is rocking and
rolling and and and things are a little
unsteady and people are kind of leaving
the ship and people are kind of
abandoning their causes with these
people they hold
right throughout the storm because they
they have a true North Star they truly
are focused it becomes an it comes an
anchor in their life that just holds
them steady and the anchor is a
confidence based upon a knowledge of
purpose someone said that there are two
great days in a person's life the day
that they are born and a day to discover
why I'm here to tell you a highly
successful people they've discovered why
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because John Fontana asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do I also love to know which is
John Maxwell's top ten rules had the
biggest impact on you and why leave in
the comments and I will join in the
discussion finally what they give a
quick shoutout to run dae-jung Ronda
thank you so much for buying my book it
means a lot to me who those you're
watching if you want your chains at a
shout-out in a future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and then
email in your receipt so I can keep
tracking you and give you some
acknowledgement thank you guys so much
for watching continue to believe or
whatever you're one where it is and I'll
see you soon
I've never met a person who was not
successful that didn't have a great
amount of self-discipline within their
life self-discipline and being able to
perform and being able to keep your life
on schedule and being able to keep
commitments and promises and meet
deadlines is essential to success
none of us none of us can afford to have
a life that is controlled by someone
else
or a life that is basically controlled
by our emotions I learned many years ago
that there are two kinds of people
there's the type of person who says I'm
going to wait till I feel like it before
I do it and then there's a person who
says I've got to do it so that I feel
like it one will never get anything done
because they're sterile waiting to feel
the moment to move and the other person
says no I need to move and then I will
begin to feel the moment Sonia
self-discipline is essential in your
life and in my life if we're going to
get things done so I have a challenge
for every one of you this weekend the
challenge is simple as you go through
your weekend and sometimes it's kind of
a hopefully an easier time of your week
ask yourself am i practicing
self-discipline in my life am i doing
the things that I should do because I
need to do them or am I kind of waiting
to feel the moment do like our friends
Nike say just do it how do we find our
personal Kirk camp Myers somebody who
can really speak into our lives and
change our trajectory why I can't take
credit for it I went to a seminar the
Kurt was teaching on success and when he
was when they finished teaching I went
up to him and introduced myself and I
asked for an appointment with him and
and he came to then the Lancaster to the
Holiday Inn for breakfast and we had
that breakfast meeting that did change
my life and then I never saw him again
from that time until my 65th birthday
when my staff brought I never had seen
him I talked about him and talked about
and on my 65th birthday when we were
having a party together they brought him
into the
room and I hadn't seen him for 40 years
I just wept and I thought you know but
but I think the key was when I went to
hear him and I he began to speak to my
life about being successful I I kind of
broke out of a barrier and I went up to
introduce myself and then I asked could
I take him to breakfast and could I
learn from him and I think the key is
once you see somebody that is helping
you be bold and ask them you know can I
take you to breakfast and by the way
here's the thought by the breakfast okay
yeah just don't go and say hey how about
buy breakfast for me though but but just
I I took that step and I've always been
glad I took that step but I've always
thought to myself you know what if I
wouldn't have taken the step then I
probably would have never had that
relationship but never maybe we would
have asked that question if everyone
ever would have had this seminar or
would have written written the book so I
think once you see somebody that you
think can really help you take the
initiative and step right out something
magical happens when you begin to
understand the most appreciable assets
you have in any organization is the
people of that organization and you
begin to commit yourself to develop the
people within that organization because
how do you grow a company you grow a
company by growing people and when you
grow them they increase their capacity
when they can increase their capacity
they begin to increase the capacity of
what you can do and what you can
accomplish let me just share with you
quickly three thoughts on developing
people just very quickly number one is
the key to developing leaders and if it
the key to developing good people is in
recruitment the better person you bring
in the door the higher odds you can do
well with them
I remember having lunch one time with
Lou Holtz and Lou Holtz said Johnny I've
had bad players on my football team and
I've had good players on my football
team he said just to be honest with you
I I'm a better coach with good players
of course he is of course it's good let
me let me say something 80% of your
success of equipping people to be
successful is in the front door on who
you bring in I wish I had time to
develop that for you because what
happens is unless you and I have a clear
picture of what we're looking for
we don't know when we see it happens all
the time people come to me and say John
I'm looking for some leaders for my
company
what do you suggest the first question I
ask us what what does the leader look
like give me the characteristics give me
the qualities up please please paint a
picture for me what does that leader
look like because you've got to have
that clear picture so that when you see
that person you know that they're one
that you want recruitment is key number
two is positioning the ability not only
to bring the right person in the right
in the in the front door but also to put
them in the right place as comments
would say get them on the bus get them
on the right seat and position is huge
and what I've discovered is that
successful people have always positioned
them well themselves well would you see
a successful person they're successful
because what they have done is they've
found their strengths on and they found
their niche and they stay right in that
sweet spot and they just work that sweet
spot you've never heard anybody be an
interview that was successful that you
came up and you interviewed and they
said well the secret of my success is
that I've never discovered what I was
good at or the serum.i successes I've
always worked on I've just I've just
worked in my weakness it no no they're
always in their strength they always
they've already discovered what they're
good at now successful people have
discovered what they're good at
successful leaders discover what other
people are good at successful people
position themselves well successful
leader position that other people well
and at level number four that's exactly
what happened the leader is always
looking at the people observing watching
just like last week I went back to my my
first school I graduated I graduated
from a higher Christian University in a
little town in circle Ohio and and it's
a little school I go back every year and
I give them a day to just speak and they
get all the proceeds and keep the money
and and so because I grew up in that
town I told one of my friends that
played ball with me tear I said Tim let
the ballplayers let the
team know--let's from my high school
kids know that I'm gonna be in town and
let's have a dinner afterwards and we
had over 50 people came together I
hadn't seen many of these had seen many
of my high school mates since I
graduated from high school clear back in
1965 we had a wonderful time we laughed
and talked and told stories for two
hours and coach Neff our basketball
coach he came back I hadn't seen him for
years and when I saw him I thought of
myself and I thought of a packet in
those scrimmages in basketball because
the first scrimmage every year coach
Neff would take the first team and he
say now I'm going to let you play the
second team but there's one condition
the first team is not going to play
their position and he'd take Doug Roth
who was six foot eight and put him out a
point guard I remember he stacked me one
year under the under center and and he
put all the first-team players out of
position on offense but he left the
second team play in their position and
the second team always beat us and the
scrimmage why'd they always beat us
because and then he would stop and he
say let me just explain something to you
no matter how talented you are if you're
out of position you'll never reach your
potential what was coach Neff teachings
he was coaching us and he was teaching
us that it's key to get positionally
corrected it's also as a leader key to
get your people in the right position
and a level number four that's what
happens at level number four you recruit
well you position well and then you
equip well now you take them and say
okay I understand what their strengths
own is I understand what their
giftedness is now I'm going I'm going to
equip them I'm going to come alongside
of them and I'm going to develop them
and I'm going to train them and I use a
very simple four years for many many
years a simple five-step equipping
process it really works step one I do it
it's that simple
you can't teach somebody which can't do
yourself yeah we may teach what we know
but we reproduce while we are so if
you're going to reproduce yourself
you've got to be it yourself so the
first step is is I do it step two as I
do it and you're with me I take you with
me now we're gonna spend together I'm
going to be your mentor I'm going to be
your coach you're going to watch me
you're going to observe me you're going
to see me in different situations we're
going to make sure that it works
going to make sure you want to be able
to ask me questions step three is that
now we turn it and I had I hand the ball
off to you now on step three you do it
you do it and I'm with you now I'm
watching you and I'm tweaking you and
I'm getting I'm helping you to get
better and I I'm I'm I'm just really
fine-tuning you step four as you do it
you just do it you don't need me anymore
you know how to do it you do it you do
it well and many times people think that
equipping stops at step four but it
doesn't there's one more step that's
absolutely essential Step five is is is
you do it in somebody's with you you've
never really trained and equipped
somebody until they can multiply
themselves that's where all compounding
is that's where all compounding the time
money influence the whole process
compound he begins when you can train
somebody who has trained somebody I know
that well because fourteen years ago I
started a nonprofit organization called
equip that is now the largest leadership
organization in the world and we've
trained and equipped over three million
people in 154 countries and the key to
that is we don't train anybody unless
they make a commitment to train somebody
else it has to continue to go on that's
level number four it's a beautiful level
to be on it's the level where you
develop people